it seems like you would be able to do
the splits in just a few weeks but it's
really not that simple
full disclosure I am NOT very flexible
at all is there like skinny stretch
jeans I feel like I'm about as stiff as
they come it's about as far as I can go
I feel like flexible people can save
lives because they can like flexible we
move into little spaces I hate this
hurts right here I want to be able to do
the splits because I want that
flexibility back I don't I think
honestly I think this is as far as I can
go I want to feel those muscles stress
okay that hurts Yeah right there my goal
is to do better than this and to
actually hit hit this each morning and
eat tonight we're gonna be doing some
stretches to increase our flexibility so
that the end of this challenge I can do
the dream splits that I've always wanted
to do okay guys let's do some stretches
we have to do 10 minutes of stretching
every morning today's the first day or
I'm gonna try and use these bands so I
can learn how to do the splits
smells so weird
so I have to do a lunge a leg stretch a
standing stretch and then drive it a
split slide your front foot forward lean
back and slowly lower yourself to the
ground we're supposed to be doing 10
assists stretching and trying to hold
him but I'm going to tell you what it
turns a lot stretching kind of hurts
sometimes and they always tell you in
stretching videos like stretch into the
vein breathe into the pain flexibility
is hard but sometimes you're just like
this painful uber and pretty done to it
it's like a lot and I don't want to do
this anymore
you can tell how out of shape I am with
literally just stretch a lot of
spreading of the legs a lot of bending
over a lot of putting your legs on top
of things
at first it hurt a lot to stretch as
much as it needed YouTube for like every
single morning but the more and more I
got into it the better and easier it was
one of the funny stretches that I really
like is like doing it I think it's the
wall you put your butt as close to the
wall as possible
mom are you proud of me I also went to
bar class do you do the workout you do a
stretch at the end and the stretch feels
incredible after a workout I'm gonna go
home
see I can do something with my muscles
super toasty it's supposed to be doing a
split in the next week and I still feel
like I barely made progress I think it's
just like kind of Midway was a little
bit of a mental challenge and I
literally I'm supposed to do these
stretches but I don't want to they got
to push through you gotta make yourself
as flexible as possible I don't want to
do the statue ladies keep the pose for
25 to 35 seconds all the time focusing
on your breathing
oh you've like one more wait I've got to
be able to do that split in the next
week
I imagine someday soon I'll be able to
move my knee to my nose it feels good to
stretch it like there's something to it
I feel like I can touch my toes a little
bit easier now which is a good sign I
used to not be able to touch my toes at
all these stretches I kind of did it as
a way almost like meditation so it's
kind of like my morning wake-up kind of
stretch my fiancee was definitely a
little annoyed at my stretching cuz I
kept doing it while watching TV and I'd
like kick my leg and that was the best
time to stretch for me I might as well
you make some use out of my time a big
setback for me was an injury ahead of me
injury I actually ran the New York City
Marathon and halfway through the
marathon and he kind of gave out well my
knee hurts and there's no one cheering
many hurt still jeez this is not exactly
going away I wanted it you but I'm gonna
finish this damn marathon there's a
little bit painful for about a week but
it also affected my stretching for
splits
my knees hurt really bad some of the
fatty some if you have an injury it's
always good to like stretch it out
loosen it up and kind of makes it heal
quicker okay oh my god I still got like
six inches to go down you're pretty
close though yeah I definitely think I
became more flexible yeah I know I can
reach my toes a lot better now I think
there's probably a 25% chance of success
for me to do this but maybe like that
performance pressure will help me do a
split
oh that's better already the stretching
I've done has made me more flexible I
guess let's try that dream split that
I've never been able to do ever in my
life I think this just goes to show that
I need to more fully commit to things I
think I should have been stretching more
like civility man Phil's Katoon for your
best interest I want to be lower to the
ground and I want to have straighter
legs so that's what I'm going for
that's about as low as I can go but
feels strong I feel strong and I feel
better
but I definitely think I can at least
push past that this time 22 I kicked
this thing's ass yeah I know about doing
that the split still stretching over is
a little bit different than like
spreading your legs good marker it's not
another proper form so you kind of have
to go into a lunge and then slowly and
gradually make your way down instead of
just like popping right into this so
let's try oh my god you Wow Wow perfect
I just surprised myself
[Music]
this feels so weird it gave me the
confidence to feel a lot more flexible
like I can definitely do it I can kick
the face I really need to looks good I
think that's the best takeaway if you're
trying to do a split be diligent like
you actually do the stretches seeing
gains and flexibility seeing my progress
like in numbers does that move you like
you know what I think I can actually do
this if you're starting out from kind of
an inflexible standpoint it'll probably
take you like a good three or four
months before you be able to do a split
but I do see improvement so stretching
consistently does make you more flexible
it's just about how consistent you are
with the stretching yeah check my check
my social media I'll post if I'm able to
do a split in the next few months